[Music]
while the first dragon seen in this
franchise were drogon viserion and
rhaegal the origins of these majestic
beasts date back thousands of years in
the past
they were first brought to westeros the
western continent of that world by aegon
targaryen and his sisters and the
dragons that came along with them were
valerian the black dread veigar and
miraxis
then by the time of the house of the
dragon around 120 years after aegon's
conquest there were around 20 of these
flying giant creatures and as the
showrunners have confirmed they have
diverged into three different breeds in
the show so what are their origins and
how did they evolve
there are various origin stories laid
forth in the books for the dragons of
that world the valyrians one is the most
common it is said that in the foreign
fires a line of volcanoes that span the
neck of the valyrian peninsula their
ancestors discovered the eggs are the
first known dragons
these dragons were tamed by the
valyrians who were at first peaceful
shepherds and then turn into the dragon
riders we see today they even learn how
to control and ride them as war animals
then in the show house of the dragon the
second episode we are given a hint that
valyria was nestled in the crater of an
active volcano which is linked to the
magic of the dragons
also it was said that the mages perform
blood magic so that the riders and the
dragons are bonded by both fire magic
and blood
hence why only people from valyrian
descent can write them
in another origin story according to the
legends in garth a city in the far east
of the continent of essex a second moon
in the sky was scorched by the sun and
it split like an egg and let loose a
million dragons which came down to earth
and made it their home
for the east there is a different story
and these dragons are thought to have
originated in the islands of the jade
sea and maybe the shadow lands beyond
asshai summoned to the world by dark and
blood magic
but according to legends from asshai
before disappearing from history an
unidentified people first tamed these
dragons and transported them to valyria
and taught the valyrians how to bond
with them and ride the bees
but the most interesting origin story of
the dragons is that they were bred and
hybridized using magic by the valyrians
in the land of the fourteen fires they
are thought to be a mix of wyverns and
fire worms the first one the wyverns are
a species of animal that lived in
cetharius or the southern continent and
are akin to dragons although they do not
breathe fire they have leathery wings
cruel beaks and an insatiable hunger the
fire worms however are creatures that
breathe fire but have no wings and are
possibly related to dragons they can bow
through rock soil and love to be
underground and they have been found in
valyria long before the dragons came to
be in that place
so if we think for a minute here like
really think about it we can see why
this theory has such an appeal the
weapons are winged creatures with two
wings and two short legs and long tails
but yet they can't breathe fire and they
have beaks which are notable differences
because dragons have mouths with rows of
sharp teeth
the fire worms however were serpentine
creatures that although can breathe fire
had no wings and were either limbless or
had short arms and legs
so if the valyrians were to combine or
with magic breed the two species the
resultant offspring would carry on the
characteristics of its different parents
hence the dragons would look like rivens
in having wings and legs have serpentine
bodies like fire worms and breathe fire
just as the ladder does
and also love to make their homes in
caves or underground
so take your pick on your preferred
origin story
let's get to the other elephant in the
room the different breeds of dragons
so while these dragons are enormous fire
breathing wicked reptiles with long
serpentine bodies that have two long
forelimbs with wings and two short back
legs and the entire body is covered with
scales
there are notable differences however
between individuals like very different
as in saint bernard versus chihuahua or
pomeranian difference
with not just size but the body design
and even skull structure so the question
now rises how did they come to be
different and what are the differences
well the first dragons that actually
came to westeros to dragonstone were
valerian and four others that were
unnamed so when the targaryens resettled
on dragonstone to escape the doom of
valyria they took five dragons along
with them but four of these later died
leaving only baler in the black dread
the only dragon that was born in the
valyrian peninsula however the other
dragons did leave behind eggs from which
hatch miraxis and veigar
these two dragons might have come from
two different stocks that had a
different body design as well as
temperament and size so
since the showrunners have said that
there are three different breeds of
dragons it is safe to presume that
valerion moraxis and vega were different
breeds and from them came their own
respective lineage of dragon birds
so how different are they
well they do have the same abilities and
general characteristics since they are
the same species but the differences
come in a skull shape body design wings
and tail
drogon and the other two are said to
look like valerion so this breed had a
robust body with massive wings and have
heads that are shaped like a t-rex or a
dinosaur with horns all over
the second breed is the one with the
wolf-like skull and maybe has a
serpentine body as in the case of
karaxis and if i may add miraxis since
we can cancel out vega to be having a
worm-like body appearance
the third breed would have a skull that
is somewhere in between a canine and a
dinosaur more like a horse and this
breed would have a body design similar
to the first balerian breed but not as
scaly or robust and with lesser horns
and sharp outgrowths as we can see in
the case of veigar and cyrax in the show
house of the dragon
and so with that we come to the end of
it so i hope you have enjoyed watching
this video on the different breeds of
dragons and their origins so do hit the
like button for support subscribe and
ring that bell icon for regular updates
on new videos here on this channel till
the next one take care fam